sri lanka has declared a state of
emergency just hours after president
gotabaya rajapaksa fled to the maldives
the prime minister ranil victor masinga
has declared himself acting president
police have fired tear gas at protesters
calling for his resignation
thousands of people have converged on
his offices in colombo let's go straight
to step vassen who's live for us in
colombo steph it's been a very eventful
24 to 48 hours in uh in sri lanka bring
us up to date with the very latest
well a lot of anger here on the streets
of colombo as you can see here behind me
a lot of protesters went to the prime
minister's office just over an hour ago
their police fired tear gas and water
cannons
to them and then they started marching
around the city
thousands of them and now they have
arrived here at the state television and
radio offices basically what we're
seeing right now is that the prime
minister has declared a state of
emergency in the western provinces and
also imposed emergency measures for the
whole country basically also saying that
people who are rioting could be arrested
but a lot of people are demanding his
resignation as well the main demand
right now because we haven't heard from
president gotabaya rajapaksa since he
fled sri lanka in the early hours of
today together with his wife and two
bodyguards he's now in the maldives but
they also want the prime minister anil
kamisinga to resign as well that's their
main demand that's what they're shouting
here i can show you around you can see
also now in the last couple of hours a
different mood than in the last few days
you see that a lot of military and
police is now
on the streets they're blocking
the areas of the elites they're also
blocking here the state television you
can see the military is basically
protecting this building and we've seen
that around the city center that the
military is really back on the street
right now
possibly also because of this state of
emergency of which many people are now
questioning uh the legality the
spokesman of the prime minister has just
explained to journalists that the legal
explanation for the
fact that the prime minister is calling
himself an acting president without the
official resignation of the president
will follow later that's what he said he
said we want the situation to be under
control first okay so let's just pick up
on that point
again step
just to clarify
as we understand from a legal point of
view
he the prime minister can't call himself
acting president kenny until the prime
minister has officially
declared himself
sent out an official letter of
resignation we haven't seen that letter
of resignation yet
no we haven't seen an official letter of
resignation and also the president
before fleeing the country has not
appointed an acting president the
speaker of parliament has confirmed this
to journalists so there is a legal limbo
a power vacuum at the moment so to say
so the prime minister is now stepping in
there's a lot of speculation that he
wants to stay in his position and even
wants to become the next president and
that's something that a lot of people
here on the streets really don't want to
see that's one of the main demands they
say the prime minister is also
supporting
he is involved in everything that
happened the country is bankrupt he has
been part of this they want him to be
out of office as well he's reportedly
still in sri lanka at the moment and
he's apparently also pulling the strings
right now
let's take a step back
to how exactly the president got to buy
rajapaksa managed to leave the country
do we have more specific details about
how
he managed to flee and do we know where
his final destination is
[Music]
well let me see first what's happening
here there's a lot of
anger now at the military
guarding the office because the state
television has been
a mouthpiece of the rajapaksa family
that's why they're so angry here at the
state television offices and radio
offices i'm sorry
but to your question what happened is
that the president apparently already
went to an air base close to the
to the airport yesterday didn't manage
to get out and this morning he uses
executive powers
and used an aircraft by the air force to
leave so basically he got
the promise
that he could leave there was a deal
made apparently that he could actually
leave the country there was a lot of
discussion about it last night and a lot
of people were surprised this morning to
see that he actually managed to flee
[Music]
they're saying that they're happy in a
way that he's gone that he is out of the
picture right now but a lot of people of
course are also calling for him to be
brought to justice
because they say
they were not only huge mismanagement of
the country but there's also been
murders of journalists there's a lot of
people put in prison they also ask for
political prisoners to be released but
mismanagement has brought the country to
bankruptcy in just three years time one
of the things that the president did was
for example stopping the import of
chemical fertilizer
saying farmers should be organic
from one day to the other and that
basically affected a lot of farmers and
also
the export of tea for example in the
country that was one of the reasons that
the country went bankrupt also huge debt
uh especially from china
there was a lot of borrowing of money
into unsuccessful projects so basically
the people here say we are now suffering
from the fact that the country is
bankrupt that we have
very little to eat and the president is
now
safe and well in the maldives and
probably going to dubai that's what
people say he's going to dubai after the
maldives that's where he wants to be an
exile
okay for now steph uh we'll leave it
there steph vassen outside the official
tv studios in colombia colombo the
situation obviously evolving very fast